regenerate medical concierge the
sponsors of this next segment are here
to help women post menopause we stopped
by their offices to find out how
[Music]
hi i'm dr amin and this is regenerate
medical concierge my practice and we do
iv vitamin therapy and anti-aging
modalities here
in the new year we get a lot of people
that come in they want to start the year
off on the right foot and they come in
looking for health and wellness
optimization
one of the things we do here is
bioidentical hormone replacement therapy
or bhrt for short essentially it's a
replacement of hormones for
perimenopausal and postmenopausal women
the female body after menopause drops
off in its hormone production and our
goal here is to optimize those levels so
that women can live their best lives
when a patient inquires by phone email
or coming into the clinic our first
objective is to give them a
questionnaire which has a majority of
the symptoms that women may encounter
through perimenopause and into menopause
based on the answers to the
questionnaire if i think they
fit the bill and are a good candidate
we'll have them arrange a consult where
they formally sit down with me that
process usually takes about an hour
where
the the optimal uh way that that meeting
goes is i get to find out everything
about what's going on with them what's
gone on with them throughout their lives
and
then we move to doing lab work and the
lab work will show me an elaborate
picture of exactly what's going on and
after further discussions and review of
that lab work we determine the optimal
doses to start at and then continue to
monitor them very closely one of the big
things i like to do is make sure that
they have
access to me i find that
you know having a follow up every few
weeks to months doesn't work as well as
having a follow-up every couple of days
to make sure that we're optimizing
symptom reduction so that they continue
to feel better
one of the things we strive for here is
the convenience and being a one-stop
shop and essentially we do our lab work
and medication orders all in-house we
use only registered nurses
in our clinic we do the blood work here
the results come to us and we send them
to the patient as soon as we receive
them as for the medications we also
order those here and the patient can
pick them up when they come in for their
rooster shots
one of the reasons women choose to come
here for their bio-identical hormone
therapy is they do see a rapid
improvement in their symptoms primarily
based on
them having access to my cell phone and
email so that we can be constantly
communicating to make changes to the
medication as soon as we start we've had
numerous patients that right from the
jump within the first week are feeling
much much better 90 to 100 resolution of
their symptoms
and again that's based on having the
extensive lab work extensive follow-up
with me and then staying in constant
communication
this is regenerate medical concierge
we're located at the district at gvr and
we implore you to come in and check us
out we have tons of different services
we offer and our number one goal here is
to help you look and feel your best
thank you regenerate medical concierge
for sponsoring that segment you can
visit them in henderson for more
information call
702-998-8009 or head to
regeneratemedicalconcierge.com